American top top man Harvard studied
on Wall Street for a long time and
now wants to
open a lot of shops there in a very short time with you and
with us how are you?
We wanted to sell our location
on Mallorca we have a
location  in Mallorca and he got
in touch and then we could
n't do the transaction because the
existing franchise owner did
n't want to sell and then he said
I'm from Houston and in
Mallorca I'm actually only
a big Mallorca fan on vacation  and
then he said yes Mar stop Mar h I
live there and there is only Starbucks
and Dutch Brothers are the ones with the
energy drinks and I have the valuation
of Dutch Brothers somehow 400 400
locations 6 billion dollars on the
stock market and let's  do that too